je me suis la voix bonjour merci nous
avons écrit on fait plaisir
vous vous demandez pourquoi il n'y a pas
de nids-de-poule sur le tablier du pont
qui à un partout ailleurs exactement oui
je trouve ça un peu spécial pour casque
you ils y ont construit le port d'une
façon différente des autres places dans
au québec
aussi c'est particulier au pont parce
que s'est incliné ou chocolat comme
d'autres citoyens vous trouvez qu'il ya
beaucoup de mythes paul cette année
particulièrement ben je pense que c'est
dû aux changements de température il ya
fait très froid il ya eu de la pluie ce
duel je pense que ça c'est la cause
principale
mais pourquoi nous route treiziste pas
plus que ça c'est une très bonne
question savez vous quoi on va aller la
pause et aux grands spécialistes du
bitume à le ts au quai école de
technologie supérieure à montréal dont
on vous donne la réponse après parfait
merci beaucoup
alain kan que bonjour aux sommes à le ts
vous êtes professeur votre chef de ce
laboratoire la exact la question que les
gens se posent et que notre citoyenne
nous a posé comment se fait-il qu'on
n'arrive pas à faire un matériau qui va
résister aux fissures et qui donc va
résister au fameux nids de poule ont
réussi à faire des matériaux qui résiste
aux fille sur les épaules c'est un autre
histoire pour qu'on n'ait même pas sur
les routes on les met sur les routes
mais les matériaux ont une durée de vie
donnée mais c'est quoi ça donne quoi une
année ou deux c'est non si c'est parce
qu'il faut comprendre qu'une chaussée
c'est une structure comme un sandwich ya
plein plein de couches donc si on ne
fait que changer la couche du dessus
c'est comme changer seulement la
peinture sur un mur
si le mur est fissurée change la
peinture ben je verrais pas là fut
cependant pas très longtemps donc il
faut changer plus profondément dans la
structure mais ça ça demande plus de
fond ça coûte plus cher donc on n'a pas
tendance à le faire
oui mais quand même là on voit des
routes neuves qui ont été refaites par
montréal y en a plusieurs des routes
neuves
un an après il ya des cracks
c'est pas normal ça c'est parce que la
route ont pas été refaite comme vous
dites donc tout ce qu'on a fait c'est
enlever une petite couche au dessus qui
est en mauvais état donc on appelle ça
un planage et on à refaire resurfaçage
on en a remis la même épaisseur
donc on ne peut pas réparer la route en
profondeur mais si on répare la route en
profondeur combien de temps peut-on
rouler sur une route comme ça s'inquiète
fissures et donc s'inquiète de
nids-de-poule voyez unis paul arrive
beaucoup plus tard s'inquiète fille sur
six est en parfaite état tout a été bien
fait selon dimensionnement surface
facilement on peut se rendre dizaine
d'années ça qu'on voit quoi que ce soit
voyons sur le manque d'entretien nos
problèmes on envoie des fusées spatiales
en a vu david saint jacques avec des
-150 degrés on est on voit sur la lune
on va aller sur mars
[Applaudissements]
vous me dites qu'on peut pas imaginer un
matériau meilleur que le bitume vieux
comme il ya mille ans j'ai pas que cela
combien de temps qu'on fait ça ils ont
vaincu les plus résistants et qui va
s'adapter chaleur froid qui va moins une
fissure et on n'est pas rendu là non on
est rendu là donc oui on est capable de
faire certains enrobé ou de développer
ici des enrobés à très hautes
performances qui sont vraiment très
performant en fatigue ont froid etc
c'est des matériaux qui coûte plus cher
et qui sont un peu différents impose
donc c'est la construction comme
beaucoup d'autres domaines et un peu
réfractaires au changement
donc il faut faire attention mais yo
réellement un effort qui est faite de
l'industrie l'industrie essaie de
prendre ça mais avec des fonds limités
mais pourquoi il ya autant là autant de
nids poule le nid-de-poule cesser la fin
de vie les nids de poule c'est parce
qu'il ya une dégradation et je m'en suis
pas occupé je n'ai pas entretenu
correctement
donc si je fais une maintenance courait
qu'il n'y a pas d'eau qui rentrent dans
ma structure de chaussée jeu devrait
limiter le nombre de nikon on doit
réparer les nids paul on n'a pas le
choix c'est une question de sécurité
donc je crois qu'on n'a rien trouvé de
meilleur que le bitume pour l'est pour
l'instant non mais ce qu'on essaie de
faire ce que nous et d'autres centres de
recherche des entreprises travaillent ce
essayer de trouver un remplaçant au
bitume qui n'est pas un produit
pétrolier dont quelque chose qui n'est
pas et dérivés du pétrole questions de
développement durable quelque chose de
plus vers puis jusqu'à maintenant il ya
quelques gros groupes qui ont des
produits qui sont bien sûr c'est fait
avec des plantes avec de l'huile de
colza des choses comme ça donc ça
fonctionne plutôt bien
c'est plus cher c'est vrai un
désavantage c'est que cc parle c'est
transparent des fois concourra un peu
comme du miel puis rajouter de la vitre
ça fait quoi rajouter du verre à la base
c'est simplement que ce soit plus vert
plus recyclable plus développement
durable et tout mais est ce qu'on s'est
aperçu dans les derniers
nos derniers essais c'est qu'au niveau
îlots de chaleur ça n'impacte surprenant
donc vous dites que ce n'est au visage
les matériaux c'est la mauvaise cible
dit le matériau est correct la lave dans
beaucoup de cas le matériau est correct
mais on fonctionne beaucoup avec le plus
bas soumissionnaire conforme et non pas
avec une performance demandée souvent
donc ça c'est un autre problème
alors vous dites on a pris un retard
énorme dans l'entretien ouais on
n'arrive pas aux comme le che courante
exact l'exacte et donc ça craque plomb
patch à crack au patch en faisant
l'équivalent de ce qu'on fait maintenant
qu'on s'améliore lentement pour vite
mais c'est clair qu'il faut augmenter le
budget faut pas juste maintenir le
budget ou ce qu'on est là pour
l'entretien et la maintenance des
chaussées et quand on dit que les routes
sur le plus belle aux états unis il ya
plus de densité ya plus de monde pour
payer l'entretien
oui mais c'est pas vrai que les autres
celui sont plus belle par terre c'est si
vous avez conduit beaucoup aux états
unis il ya plein d'endroits
qu'effectivement c'est très très beau
d'autant droit ça ressemble au nôtre
donc mais oui le fait l'argent qu'on met
sur les routes
et encore une fois si vous descendez sur
la côte est il ya beaucoup de pillages
donc des fonds
[Musique]
donc c'est l'argent malheureusement en
partie sert au soleil
ce n'est pas la technologie la réponse
c'est celle entre eux c'est l'argent
la technologie c'est une partie de la
réponse parce qu'on essaie de faire des
matériaux qui sont le plus durable
possible et tout et qui vont coûter le
moins cher possible et le plus vert
possible notre citoyen se demander aussi
comment se fait-il que sur le tablier du
pont jacques-cartier c'est impeccable
est ce que c'est parce que c'est pas la
nature du
du lieu où c'est parce que justement
comme vous dites on l'entretient mieux
il ya une question en entretien ça c'est
certain mais deuxième chose c'est que la
structure sur un pont la base est
extrêmement rigide elle ne devrait pas
se dégrader très rapidement devrait pas
donc on met par dessus une couche pour
l'imperméabilité donc pour rendre
étanche et tout ce qui nous reste c'est
maître de l'enrobé pour rendre soit
sécuritaire confortable et autres donc
la structure est un peu plus simple à
faire de ce côté là il ya les joints
qu'il faut travailler mais le reste
normalement si c'est bien fait ça
devrait durer comme à londres que c'est
l'ex le pot est l'exemple d'une route
qui devrait défaite on devrait être
capable de faire des routes comme exacts
exact ce caractère on va devoir remplir
une épaule quelques années encore
exactement
merci beaucoup bien à quoi
[Musique]